shot a scene with another man for the
first time in the seven years that I've
been shooting I've always shot with my
husband and like eight days ago
something like that I was like I'm gonna
go do my scene I came home and I feel
like it was a little rough because it
was new territory like we didn't really
know our boundaries yet
um we have had a threesome with another
guy it was just like very very early and
it wasn't even a relationship I was like
he was a [__] boy and I was the girl he
was [__] and like we had a threesome
one night and we never talked about it
again it was like taboo to talk about we
just pretended it didn't happen but like
Adam and I have always been just down to
have some fun sexual experiences but
then as he fell like more in love with
me and I fell in love with him he was
just like I can't do that with you and
another guy I can't see with another guy
just like it wasn't gonna work for us
why is my question like why would you
like I want to know
to know the number over how much are you
making up